teaching isn't an easy job take it from
these movie mentors and their students
who's the jedi with a family problem
which beleaguered bride had the worst
wedding day ever and what the heck is up
with tyler durden keep watching to find
out
the first film in christopher nolan's
dark knight trilogy batman begins is an
origin story that hinges on what bruce
wayne learns and rejects from the man he
knows as henry dicard the card trains
wayne to fight and offers him the
opportunity to join the league of
shadows yet when descartes and the man
that wayne believes to be raz al-ghul
inform him that the league intends to
destroy gotham he burns their
headquarters down wayne makes it crystal
clear that he disagrees with the
league's evil plot but he's still loyal
to his mentor and so he saves the card
from the destruction that decision comes
back to haunt him though when descartes
shows up in gotham he reveals that he's
the real raz al-ghul and that he still
plans on tearing down the crime-ridden
city despite the objections of his
appalled protege of course wayne is
unwilling to give up on gotham the two
engage in their final confrontation on a
train in which a confident roz seems to
be sure he'll win that confidence is
misplaced he has grossly underestimated
batman who is willing to let the train
crash instead of stopping it as raz had
wrongly assumed i won't kill you
but i don't have to save you
just as roz realizes what's about to
happen the caped crusader flies away
leaving his former mentor to his fate
quentin tarantino's two-part tour de
force kill bill centers on a woman known
for most of the story as the bride who
leaves the assassination squad she is a
member of after learning she is pregnant
when bill the squad's leader discovers
she is getting married and starting over
he and the other assassins crash the
wedding and kill everyone apart from her
it's not through lack of trying however
bill shoots her in the head just as she
tells him that the baby she's carrying
is his four years later the bride wakes
up from a coma and immediately sets out
to kill every last one of her old
comrades saving the most important
target for last when the bride
eventually comes face to face with her
former lover and mentor in kill bill
volume 2 bill reveals that their
daughter survived and that he's been
raising her this isn't enough to gain
her forgiveness though accepting that
she won't be talked down bill attacks
the bride the two engage in a brief but
thrilling battle in which the bride
sheaves spills sword and then performs
the five point palm exploding heart
technique on him bill's death doesn't
exactly come as a shock but it's still
an immensely satisfying showdown
several mentors have clashed with their
proteges over the course of the marvel
cinematic universe a trend that started
in 2008's iron man the movie begins with
tony stark the ceo of weapons
manufacturer stark industries being
kidnapped during an ambush in
afghanistan stark is subsequently held
captive in a cave for months on end
during this time he invents the first
iron man suit as well as the miniature
arc reactor that powers it enabling his
escape upon returning home he's relieved
to be reunited with his friends
including obadiah stayne his father's
former business partner and tony's
mentor what stark doesn't know is that
stain has been plotting to have him
killed this whole time even engineering
the kidnapping attempt against him when
that doesn't work out and stain learns
that stark has miniaturized the arc
reactor he takes that from tony instead
right out of his chest knowing that
stain plans to use his invention to
create weapons he powers up his iron man
suit with another reactor and goes after
stain unfortunately stain has created
his own far larger suit making it an
uneven fight from the start so when
stark realizes he can't physically beat
stain he orders pepper to overload stock
industries arc reactor sending a surge
of electricity through stained suit and
killing the man inside
the star wars franchise contains
numerous examples of mentors coming to
blows with their proteges a prime
example takes place during the last jedi
in which kylo ren and his uncle luke
skywalker face off in battle kylo was
known as ben solo when he was sent to
train with luke to become a jedi sadly
supreme leader snoke soon wormed his way
into the young apprentice's head luring
him to the dark side when ben woke up
one night to find luke standing over him
with a lightsaber he lashed out in fear
and confusion finally giving up on the
light side of the force by the time he
meets luke again kylo has killed snoke
and taken over as supreme leader of the
first order he initially tries to use
the first order's overwhelming firepower
to kill his one-time master
do you think you got him when luke
emerges unscathed kylo engages him in a
lightsaber duel one that is made all the
more intense by their fractured
relationship at first the crazed kylo
struggles to land a blow on the wise
jedi and when he eventually manages to
run his weapon through him he realizes
that luke isn't really there he's
projecting himself to give the
resistance time to escape
his ruse uncovered luke vanishes he then
passes away from the effort of his
projection confident that the resistance
and the jedi will live on
while the title character is the focus
of doctor strange his pursuit of the
magical arts place him in the middle of
a struggle between his mentor the
ancient one and her former student
cacillius while strange is told that
cassilius wants to bring dormammu from
the dark dimension to earth in a bid to
give everyone eternal life he isn't told
why cecilia's turned against the ancient
one as it turns out cassilius became
disenchanted with the ancient one when
he learned that she has been drawing
power from the dark dimension to extend
her life because of this betrayal when
the ancient one tells cassilius that
bringing dormammu to earth will end in
pain he doesn't believe her eventually
strange and his ally mordo are forced to
fight cassilius in the mirror dimension
just when it seems as though they're
outmatched the ancient one appears
pushing her current proteges to the side
and taking on cassilius and his
followers alone she gets the upper hand
at first but cecilia stabs her in the
abdomen and kicks her through a portal
into the real world where she falls to
the ground from several stories up
despite strange's best efforts nothing
can be done to save her
rocky 5 begins with rocky balboa
reveling in his win over ivan drago
which took place in the previous movie
but he and his family soon fall on hard
times the head trauma he suffered in the
ring has forced him to retire from
boxing and to make matters worse his
accountant has squandered all of his
money so rocky decides to move back to
his old rough and tumble philadelphia
neighborhood where he reopens his late
trainer mickey's gym it's here that
rocky meets tommy gunn a boxer who all
but begs rocky to train and manage him
man i'm sorry but what do you think well
i think i don't think you listen too
good but you you fight you brawl like
you was a street fighter inspired by his
memories of mickey rocky agrees and
quickly becomes preoccupied with tommy's
career he ushers tommy to success but
tommy grows resentful when he realizes
that he's seen as little more than an
avatar of rocky himself at the same time
slimy promoter george washington duke
starts bending tommy's ear about the
riches he could amass if george took
over his management tommy goes for the
deal but after winning a championship
and being told it means nothing because
he didn't beat rocky he goes to rocky's
gym and calls him out when tommy refuses
to back down rocky challenges him to a
street fight while rocky easily beats
his protege at first tommy attacks from
behind and practically knocks his former
mentor out of course rocky quickly comes
back and eventually triumphs proving to
everyone that he's the real champion
early on in chiang chi and the legend of
the ten rings the protagonist is known
simply as sean nobody in his adopted
home of san francisco is aware that sean
is actually shang chi the son of shu
wenwu owner of the titular rings and
head of a criminal empire his reasons
for keeping his family a secret are
understandable after his mother was
killed his dad started to treat him like
a member of his personal army training
him to be a killer when the opportunity
arose the traumatized chongqi ran away
from home a decade later wen wu finds
shang qi and takes him back to his
compound by force shanxi doesn't believe
his father when he tells him that he's
been hearing his mother's voice who is
claiming she's held captive in her
homeland of tallow concerned chongqi
goes to tallow ahead of wenwu and learns
that his father is being fooled by the
soul-eating dweller in darkness who the
community is keeping sealed behind a
gate when wenwu arrives at talo and
attempts to break that gate chongqi
stands in his way the powerful winwood
gets the better of his son to begin with
but chongqi re-engages him and they have
a dramatic one-on-one battle win woo
manages to release the dweller in
darkness however and quickly realizes he
was wrong all along during the final
showdown wini sacrifices his life for
his son passing on the rings before he
dies
when the unnamed main character of fight
club meets tyler durden he's feeling
smothered by a society that prizes
material possessions over more prime
allergens tyler a compulsive man who
rails against the institutions that bind
becomes his guru by offering him a way
to rid himself of society's shackles
together they create the titular fight
club which gives the narrator the
cathartic opportunity to get his
aggressions out it isn't until well into
the movie when the narrator finally
begins to question tyler's motives that
he realizes his mentor is actually a
disassociated personality he created to
deal with his disillusionment when the
narrator wakes up after a blackout and
discovers that tyler has made plans to
blow up a series of buildings he
attempts to stop it from happening
however since tyler is always right
there with him he inevitably fights back
against the narrator to everyone else it
looks like the narrator is beating
himself to a bloody pulp and throwing
himself downstairs but to the narrator
tyler is doing it all when the narrator
comes to the realization that he really
does hold power over tyler he gains
control of tyler's gun and shoots
himself in the cheek finally eradicating
his other personality that said it's
tyler who really gets the last laugh
before the release of revenge of the
sith there may have been no single event
in movie history more anticipated than
the transformation of anakin skywalker
into darth vader he betrayed and
murdered your father
[Music]
now the jedi are all but extinct star
wars fans learned vader's backstory in
the original trilogy but it took more
than 20 years to see it play out on
screen the incident that precipitates
anakin's final transformation involves a
fight with his mentor the jedi master
obi-wan kenobi earlier in the movie
anakin falls to the dark side and is
dubbed darth vader but it's not until he
fights obi-wan on the fiery planet
mustafar that he becomes the black suit
clad baddie that fans love to hate
learning of anakin's embrace of the dark
side obi-wan enlists his wife padme to
help turn him back to the light when
they reach mustafar padme tries to
reason with anakin but when he sees
obi-wan he concludes she's betrayed him
demonstrating he's beyond saving anakin
force chokes padme and then battles
obi-wan in an epic lightsaber duel
across the lava world he is blind with
rage but obi-wan still manages to beat
him eventually cutting off anakin's legs
as well as one of his arms leaving him
broken and consumed by flames despite
this vader survives and many years later
finally kills his one-time master and
another lightsaber duel
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]